bonjour c'est alex lutz pour brut on va
déjà demander est-ce que c'est pas trop
pénible d'être reconnu dans la rue ce
que je trouve dingue parce que vraiment
d'une part samarie vraiment pas trop
donc c'est une question est d abord
parce que à la fois vous dit bah non
c'est pas si pénible et à la fois quand
c'est comme moi que ça arrive pas trop
ça vous vexe après coup vous dites ma
merde c'est vrai après tout je pourrais
être reconnu dans la rue et moi pas trop
est-ce que l'étiquette de catherine et
liliane ne me pèse pas trop ne me colle
pas trop d'une part non et d'autre part
c'est une question qui m'énerve parce
que il ya un côté tient vu que c'était
pourri est ce que ça ne pèse pas trop
alors c'est sans doute de la paranoïa
d'artistes mais ça fait un peu ça c'est
comme la coupe de cheveux tout juste si
vous avez longtemps la même coupe de
cheveux et vous changer de coupe de
cheveux
les gens ils nous disent ah enfin mais
non on sait des personnages dont on est
très fier qu'on a adoré faire et même
elle nous manque un peu alors c'est
plutôt chouette
et puis vaut mieux avoir inventé un
super personnage très pas du tout deux
personnages alex lutz est pas très
facile à dire quand même c'est vrai
c'est une histoire de concentration il
faut voir que ça fait de sacrés points
au scrabble et ça c'est un argument
important et c'est moins dur à dire que
marthe mercadier par exemple ou marthe
villalonga tout ce qui est en marche
donc je trouve que je m'en sors pas trop
mal avec mon nom lydia radio c'est hyper
dur à dire leeds et radio souvent les
gens font alex lutz bonjour donc tu
repères les dyslexiques
et vu que je le suis je les repère à
100000 il ya j'ai eu alain lutte dans un
musée dans une mise en scène fluide
d'alain lutte il doit exister alain but
devait être content axel évidemment
souvent donc ça je pense qu'il ya un
petit inconscient de patinage artistique
est ce que j'en ai pas marre de jouer
tous les soirs c'est pas vraiment une
question qui m'énerve mais c'est des
questions qui reviennent souvent
est ce que t'en a pas marre de jouer
tous les soirs en même temps on ne peut
pas dire est ce que t'en a pas marre de
faire du pain tous les jours
ou est ce que t'en a pas marre de voir
des patients tous les jours on entend
cabinets de médecins c'est normal que
les jeunes
voilà c'est normal qu'un spectacle me
fasse pas qu'une fois et est au
contraire moi j'aime bien c'est quand
même vrai autant au cinéma on peut y
avoir des journées fastidieuse long
parce qu'elles sont que technique ou
autant au théâtre c'est marrant c'est le
même objet mais quand même chaque soir
c'est un autre enjeu un autre un autre
délire un quelque chose d'autre à
trouver avec ce public là c'est comme si
le public était une seule personne
différente qu'on ne doit essayer de
séduire tous les soirs donc c'est à
chaque fois c'est à chaque fois une
vraie une nouvelle rencontre donc moi
j'aime j'aime plutôt ça c'est ça que
j'aime bien théâtre c'est que c'est
vivant au sens propre
voilà c'est ça que j'aime beaucoup